[Música]
salud en directo América de Francia 24
más Romero Sale está con nosotros en el
estudiomar buena mañana decir buenas
noches nombre estás un poco
despierta buena mañana
vamos a guardar un tema algo preocupante
porque parece que la calidad del esperma
está cayendo desde hace ya décadas y en
todo el mundo si Raúl un día anunciamos
que somos 8000 de millones y los
problemas de superpoblación que esto va
a conllevar y otro día pues anunciamos
que puede ser que nosotros mismos
estemos encontrando sin saberlo ni
quererlas la solución a ese a ese
problema es un estudio publicado en
human reproductive update ya habían
hecho una primera publicación en 2017
donde alertaban de este problema la
novedad es que ahora incluye estudios
también de África Asia América Latina
que antes no lo hacía por lo tanto por
eso podemos empezar a concluir que eso
sucede en todo el mundo y no solo en las
sociedades occidentales repasemos
primero las cifras que nos da este
estudio en 1973 el promedio
millones de espermatozoides por
eyaculación era de
335,7 millones en 2018
126,6 es menos de la mitad se ha
reducido más de un 50% en algo más de
cuatro décadas sucede lo mismo cuando
miramos el promedio de espermatozoides
por mililitro no 1001 millones versus 49
millones por mililitro vemos Esa
diferencia un descenso sustancial otro
gran aporte de por ejemplo de este
estudio Es que este declive que se ha
ido viendo a lo largo de cuatro décadas
se ha acelerado no ha sido el mismo pues
podemos al principio de los estudios no
en los años 80 que hoy en día vemos por
ejemplo aquí el sc corresponde a la
concentración ante esperma por mililitro
y tccs del conteo de espermatozoides
totales vemos que por ejemplo eso no a
partir de los años 70 el decliverado un
1,2% anual ya estamos en 2,6%, a partir
del año 2000
complicaciones entonces mar tienen estos
hallazgos Pues los autores del estudio
de hecho lanzaban una alarma y también
pedían más investigaciones escuchamos lo
este declive sustancial y persistente se
reconoce como una preocupación
significativa de salud pública se
necesita investigación para determinar
las causas de este declive y una
respuesta inmediata y focalizada para
prevenir más disrupciones de la salud
reproductiva masculina claramente como
vemos esto puede traer problemas de
fertilidad no problemas de parejas que
no puedan concebir o personas que no
puedan tener hijos El problema es que
además se cree que pues como si está
relacionado una pérdida de esta calidad
del esperma con por ejemplo vida
sedentaria o hábitos saludables eso es
un tema se cree que en verdad la mayor
correlación las principales causas están
en exposiciones desde en edad bastante
tempranas como el útero no en los
periodos de gestación a productos
tóxicos algunos plastificantes por
ejemplo pero también la polución ante el
aire la contaminación atmosférica
entonces claro el problema que estamos
viendo ahora corresponde a décadas atrás
no a personas a hombres que estaban
siendo concebidos hace décadas no
sabemos que está pasando hoy hoy en día
con los que se están gestando en este
momento Qué problema van a dar en el
futuro no Entonces eso hace que sea muy
difícil de predecir que está sucediendo
sin embargo también en algún apunte para
entender las limitaciones del estudio es
importante decir que el número de
espermatozoides no es el único parámetro
para medir la calidad del esperma
También estamos hablando Pues de formas
movilidad de muchas cosas que tienen que
ver con si al final si es posible
concebir o no entonces bueno para no
hacer sonar todas las alarmas sabemos
que todavía hay mucho Por investigar
antes de estar preocupados pero algo
está pasando algo está pasando y nos
vamos a otro tema porque alertando una
posible epidemia de cáncer en Europa sí
es una comisión de expertos la que dijo
esto en la revista científica adelante
una de las más prestigiosas del mundo
que quiso realizar el impacto de la
pandemia de covid 19 sobre la
investigación y la lucha contra el
cáncer les traemos dos cifras en los
últimos dos años desde que llegó el Kobe
19 hay 100 millones de revisiones por
cáncer que se deberían hacer para poder
detectar casos no se han hecho con
consecuencias muy claras por ejemplo un
millón de diagnósticos que se han
perdido en un millón de personas que
están viviendo con cáncer y que no lo
saben también por ejemplo denunciaron
que se interrumpieron ensayos clínicos y
es por eso que alertan que este problema
que estamos viendo ahora en el futuro se
podría traducir en lo que han llamado es
una epidemia de cáncer ahora Qué
recomiendan los expertos para poder
revertir de alguna manera esta situación
nomar claro Pues básicamente insisten en
la investigación que es lo que siempre
decimos además que pues ayudará a
combatir los problemas del futuro si
empezamos a hacer la investigación ahora
no por ejemplo piden más recursos que en
2030 se invierta 50 euros por cabeza por
habitante de Europa por habitante
europeo que es el doble de hoy en día en
investigación contra el cáncer también
que es el limen las desigualdades porque
una de las cosas que analizaban es que
la principal producción de investigación
está concentrada en Europa central y en
Europa del Norte mientras que por
ejemplo en Europa del este no se casi
investigación no se produce en el papers
no estos reportes que se publican en las
revistas también desigualdades de género
no menos del 33% de las investigaciones
están lideradas por mujeres Entonces
esta era otra de las recomendaciones que
daban Y por supuesto un llamado a
compartir esta información a Pues a
colaborar entre científicos de todo
Europa algo que se puede extender
también a todo el mundo para prevenir es
una de las enfermedades que sabemos que
además con el tiempo ya es una gran
carga va a ser cada vez mayor en muchos
lugares del mundo bueno lamentable mal
igual Muchísimas gracias como siempre
por toda la información mañana Por
supuesto más salud Gracias a ti